[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
actor and activist evan rachel wood
calls for domestic violence reforms
after allegations of abuse against
musician marilyn manson
while she's testifying in support of
jennifer's law in the case
of missing mother jennifer doulos i was
groomed into an abusive relationship
attorneys for nfl player deshaun watson
responds to sexual assault allegations
calling them unlawful and wrong four
more women come forward the quarterback
now facing 16 lawsuits an ohio sheriff
is sentenced to prison time for stealing
thousands of dollars
confiscated as evidence plus a jury is
seated as we await the start
of the derrick shoven murder trial we
asked fame forensic pathologist
what caused george floyd's death he did
not just succumb to fentanyl
during the course of this struggle law
and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
the jury in the trial of derrick shovin
has been selected
law and crimes kim johnson is in
minneapolis to explain what steps the
court is taking to prepare for opening
statements
brian security continues to be tight
here at the hennepin county courthouse
even though court is in recess now that
a jury has been set
but on monday 15 jurors will come back
to this courthouse to be
sworn in but not all of them only 14
will be sworn in
covet concerns are limiting the amount
of alternates
judge peter cahill is allowing for this
trial cahill ceded
a man who works as an accountant however
he says he'll dismiss
this 15th jur next week unless any of
the others
are unable to serve the judge says
physical space constraints
limits the number of alternates he can
include
14 will be seated that's all we have
room for
we could seat 15 if we had room but the
15th juror
uh as the last chosen will be excused on
monday of the other 14.
the whole point of this 15th juror was
to make sure that we
have 14 people show up on monday
nevertheless
i'm still not going to release the jury
pool until the jury is sworn
now cahill is taking safety precautions
in the courtroom because of covet 19 the
jurors will be spread out
and sit in individual desks during the
trial
it took over two weeks for the judge and
attorneys to go over more than 100
potential jurors
once the jury of nine women and five men
are sworn in monday the judge will
release
the entire jury pool now judge cahill
says that he expects this trial
to take about four weeks although it may
go longer depending on delays
the jury will not be sequestered during
the trial but will
during deliberations brian thanks kim
chief investigative correspondent brian
ross is here to explain
why george floyd's cause of death is
likely to be a key issue at trial
thanks brian coming up this week on
brian ross investigates
cause of death that's going to be the
central issue in the murder trial next
week
of derek chovin the official autopsy of
george floyd
did call it a homicide but left the door
open to say he also had
a potentially lethal level of the drug
fentanyl
in his system dr wecht who served more
than two decades as the coroner and
medical examiner in allegheny county
pennsylvania
has been involved or consulted in some
of the most high profile
death cases in recent memory including
elvis presley
kurt cobain jonbenet ramsey as you know
this case could well come down to
the autopsy and the findings is it
possible that he died of something other
than
the knee-to-neck restraint were there
enough drugs in his system that could
have killed
him was the heart condition enough that
could have killed him
my answer to your question uh succinctly
to begin with
is no i do not believe that
mr floyd died from fentanyl toxicity
or from hypertensive arterioscratic
cardiovascular disease or a combination
of those two yes it is true that the
fentanyl level in this case
was high enough to kill somebody but it
is also true
that people with that level and higher
levels do not die
i don't know what his tolerance level
was that may he may have built up
over the years the point is that when
he was stopped by the cops for that
counterfeit
money order whatever it was and so on he
was
somewhat you could say aggressive
he was resisting arrest you could say
you know those are other things but
that is not the scenario
that one would find of an individual who
was going to succumb
to fentanyl he did not just succumb to
fentanyl
during the course of this struggle where
where just
a a moment or so before he stopped
breathing
before he stopped speaking before he
stopped making sounds
before he stopped making any movement
and then all of a sudden
he died that is not the way it would
have happened
in this case and dr as you know the
official autopsy report
does open the door a bit for the defense
to argue in fact
that's what killed him it's not
definitive is it
no no it's not definitive and you know i
don't want to say anything of an odd
hominem nature
and i don't know the medical examiner
i'm sure he's a competent
forensic pathologist and so on but you
know uh for
a medical examiner to kind of smooth
over a a case involving
a police rated death that is about as
unexpected and atypical as it would be
well dr wick are you saying then that
the medical examiner essentially was
trying to cover up
for derek chovin and the minneapolis
police department
i would not use the word cover-up um
sounds pretty close i would use the
phraseology
kind of smooth over kind of smooth over
joining us today is former federal
prosecutor gene rossi and terry austin
gene cause of death is the biggest issue
here how do you see either side tackling
it
i love that that expert's comment
smoove over you know what i call it he's
covering up
okay the medical examiner was viewing
the evidence in the light most favorable
to mr chauvin
and rather than call it a tomato he
called it a tomato
all right but at the end of the day i
got to tell you i said this last week
the jurors are going to look at that
video and for eight minutes
46 seconds they're going to see with
their own eyes
that that knee was the major cause
of that death it could be fentanyl in
his system he could be an addict
but that need was neck you can't get
over that
you can have all the experts in the
world but that to me is where the rubber
meets the road
terry smooth over cover-up whatever you
want to call it the defense simply has
to show reasonable doubt
could this report maybe help or hurt
them well i do
think that it will all be the medical
evidence that
is the crux of this case and i do think
the video
i agree the video is going to be a huge
you know emphasis here so but let's look
at the medical evidence so you have the
medical examiner dr baker saying that
you know he thinks that the death
really could have been the drugs in a
system or a heart problem
but then you have the families doctor
saying that you know perhaps the
forensic you know expert here saying
that it could very well have been the
knee on the neck and so
i do think the jury is going to look at
the medical expert we have fowler also
who may be called
so we'll see what happens but that video
is going to play a huge role
yeah let's say a picture tells a
thousand words and what could a video
tell you
be sure to tune in to the law and crime
network for galvano gavel coverage
of the derek shogun trial in the murder
of george floyd still ahead of law and
crime daily
women of domestic abuse stepped forward
in support of jennifer's law
in memory of missing mother jennifer
doulos but first
the sentencing of a former ohio sheriff
the crime the cover-up
and the pleas for mercy to the judge as
he sent to jail for years
welcome back a former ohio sheriff is
going to prison for three years
for stealing money seized in drug raids
and then trying to put it back
law encrimes anjanet levy is in pike
county ohio for the hearing
antainette yeah brian charlie reader
really became one of the public law
enforcement faces
of one of ohio's largest ever murder
cases
now he's a prison inmate it's a stunning
fall from grace
i tried to talk to reader before he was
sentenced
are you going to have anything to say at
all no
readers spoke actually during his
sentencing he claimed he didn't take the
money seized in drug raids to spend it
on gambling as
prosecutors had claimed ritter painted
himself really as a robin hood type
character who took the money and gave it
to charitable things such as a high
school cheerleading car wash
he cried and begged the judge for
leniency saying he
wanted to be around for his family and
his father who is ill
there's nothing left for me to get or to
take from me other than my freedom
i have and i now pray that the court
will find mercy on me
and i beg the court if they see fit
to grant me community control even with
the strict distinctions
that i have proven to this court
in the past two and a half years that i
can abide by
the judge who sentenced reader she's
actually new to the case
the judge who had been presiding over it
since the beginning
had to step away from the case because
he's battling an illness
judge patricia cosgrove is known for
handing down
very tough sentences to sheriffs and
public corruption cases
she questioned reader at length about
why he took the money
and responded to his claims of receiving
treatment for post-traumatic
stress disorder because of the crimes
that he's seen
we all choose our profession and we have
to conduct ourselves
with integrity it cannot be
underestimated the damage that you have
caused
to the citizens of pike county to law
enforcement who every day get up
uh face the same sort of stresses that
you do
they they go all home at night uh they
get up in the morning
their family they don't know if they're
going to come home the
sacrifices that these men and women that
make
i think you've made a mockery of them
security was incredibly tight at the
pike county courthouse federal agents
including u.s marshals were there along
with bomb detecting dogs
there were some serious concerns about
reader's supporters showing up to press
protest and maybe some trouble coming
from that now reader became known
nationally following the 2016 murders of
eight members of the rhoden and ghillie
families
the morning of the murders reader
actually asked the ohio attorney
general's office to lead that
investigation because
he was heading up such a small sheriff's
office now reader's attorney said that
he plans to appeal
despite pleading guilty to half of the
charges or so
that he was facing uh his attorney jim
bolger told us that
he believes that some of those counts
should have been merged
brian thanks angel here to discuss the
sentencing of disgrace ex sheriff
reader is former federal prosecutor gene
rossi and terry austin
terry gene i already kind of know what
you're going to say but let me say this
anyways
when i read reader's story i saw one of
my own clients as a public defender a
person who had a regular life
was met with trauma hid an addiction
gambling and turned to a victimless
crime
maybe it's again the public defender in
me but i don't think jail solves this
probation maybe but i don't see jail
terry your thoughts
well maybe it is the public defender in
you brian because look i'm as
sympathetic as the next
guy but this guy was placed in a
position of public trust
he was the pike county sheriff you don't
get higher than that
and he had a duty to protect and serve
the people so i agree
with the judge i think he betrayed that
trust and i think
it doesn't matter that he eventually
gave the money back
you know having said all that i do have
sympathy and i do
think that he should get counseling and
understanding for his addiction but
i think he should serve jail time yeah
gene took about 14 000
returned almost 10 000 of those dollars
what do you think
oh it's not the amount of money although
14 000 in pike county
is not an insignificant amount but that
judge and terry hit the nail on the head
i once indicted a state prosecutor for
violating
brady and giglio discovery rules and
tampering with a witness
when you hold a position of trust when
you are the head honcho the head sheriff
in a county and you take money from the
till
what he did is he took money from people
who were arrested
that is disgraceful and i don't believe
for a minute he took that money and gave
it to charity
he did it because of greed and he had
the opportunity
and that man should serve three to five
years all right and three years is the
sentence he got
um i know that he did give a little bit
of money back sorry can't get to you
right now angenette but we'll continue
to follow this case
and see how the sentencing and the
appeal goes coming up on law on crime
daily
a new day means new lawsuits for nfl
quarterback desean watson
as 16 sexual assault complaints are
filed against the houston texan
plus support for domestic violence
reform after
the assumed murder of mother jennifer
doulos the celebrity testimony
[Music]
next
celebrities are speaking out in support
of a new bill in connecticut
calling for domestic violence reforms
after the assumed murder of a missing
mom
jennifer doulos doulas was reported
missing in 2019
and her body has never been found police
arrested her husband photos dulos
but he died months later of an apparent
suicide in 2017
jennifer doulo sought a restraining
order and emergency custody of her five
children
according to court records she was
denied because she was unable to show
her then separated husband
photos physically harmed her this new
bill seeks to expand the definition
of domestic violence to include cohorts
of control or
non-physical forms of abuse actress and
activist evan rachel wood
testified in support of the bill wood is
accusing her former partner
musician marilyn manson of sexually
abusing her and says she too was a
victim of coercive control
he used coercion to take photos and
videos of my naked body
and at times threatened to release them
publicly without my consent
which i later came to understand is
illegal and called revenge porn
he hacked into my phone and social media
accounts so i could not reach out for
help
he was monitoring me in a number of ways
i actually did try to get a restraining
order and i
i was denied or told i wouldn't be able
to
obtain one because i didn't have any
recent direct threats
back with us is former federal
prosecutor gene rossi and terry austin
terry thoughts on this movement and how
they are defining
uh this form of non-physical abuse
yeah you know i think it's important to
make sure that you're looking at
both mental emotional and also physical
abuse
the group behind this law they are local
mothers
and they're dedicated to improving the
family court system
so that all forms of domestic violence
are validated so
i agree with what they're doing i think
it's important and i think that they are
expanding the law so they include women
who are abused no matter what type of
abuse that is
gene sadly reform often follows tragedy
how does an idea like punishing
non-physical domestic abuse
return to a law that works well you have
a state senator from greenwich
connecticut new canaan connecticut
that has gotten a lot of pressure from
citizens to add this statute
my only concern with this law is this
how do you define coercive control you
have to be careful
due process supplies federal and state
cases is the statute
so vague i think they need a little more
meat
on the definition of coercive control it
can't be so vague
so that defendants future defendants
aren't on notice
as to what they can and cannot do i
think it's a good law it has to be very
carefully
uh structured and written i would agree
you never want to get more people
uh criminalized for a broad law that has
such a great
meaning behind it you want to get those
people who are committing the acts in
which you are creating the law for
perfect
perfect idea of both gene and terry when
we come back
16 accusers file lawsuits against
houston nfl quarterback deshaun watson
but he says at least one of them is in
it just for the money
[Music]
welcome back an arrest affidavit for the
accused boulder store shooter
is giving more insight into the deadly
rampage that killed 10 people
including a police officer ahmad alisa
is charged with 10 counts of murder
according to police witnesses called
9-1-1 to report that a man was shooting
in the parking lot
walked up to an elderly man stood over
him and shot him multiple
additional times the suspect is then
accused of entering the store
and continuing to shoot responding
officers reportedly found
officer eric talley deceased with what
appeared to be a bullet wound to the
head
police say alelisa removed his clothing
inside the store
including a green tactical vest and his
weapon he's scheduled to appear in court
for the first time
thursday morning an ohio woman accused
of murdering her six-year-old son
while trying to abandon him allegedly
hogtied and gagged her three other
children
brittany gosney is pleading not guilty
by reason of insanity
prosecutors say the children were tied
up for hours on the same day
james hutchinson was killed
investigators say gosney confessed to
trying to abandon all of her children
and believe she hit the young boy with
her car while he was chasing after her
she's accused of dumping his body in the
ohio river the boy's body has not yet
been found
an attorney for an nfl player accused of
sexual assault is calling claims by a
dozen women
harassment and plain wrong 16 women have
filed lawsuits against desean watson
the houston texans quarterback watson's
lawyer rusty hardin
says he has strong evidence that shows
one of the lawsuits is false
and calls into question the legitimacy
of the other cases as well
hardin released a signed affidavit by
watson's marketing manager
brian bernie bernie said he spoke with
the plaintiff in the third case
and the woman attempted to blackmail
watson by demanding 30 thousand dollars
in exchange for her indefinite silence
about what she stated was a consensual
encounter
according to a lawsuit watson hired the
massage therapist in december 2020
after reaching out to the woman on
instagram watson is accused of forcing
the woman to perform oral sex
attorney tony busby is representing the
woman and said last week that he plans
to submit affidavits to police
these women who are stepping forward
knew that they would face scorn and
ridicule
they all agreed to plead for the minimal
jurisdictional limits of the court
and they bring these cases for one
reason on stopping further
misconduct from this defendant
gene the sheer number of alleged victims
makes me think where there is smoke
there's got to be fire but the way busby
is going about it in the court of
opinion before the civil court
could that cause any problems for civil
or criminal cases in the future
well it could cause a lot of problems
with the criminal case just like what
they may have in a derek chauvin
trial uh murder trial uh but but i i
think in this
in this instance it will help the civil
cases i think it may hurt the criminal
cases because they won't be able to get
a
a fair and impartial jury but bear in
mind we're not at the point where
they're thinking of criminal charges
but i gotta say if mr watson is facing
uh 16 accusers oh boy
when you get into double digits uh it
that's extremely hard
a hard road to hoe uh if you're the
defendant in a civil or criminal lawsuit
especially when there's a clear mo that
all of these alleged victims are massage
therapists or masseuse in one way shape
or form
desean watson's lawyer keeps asking for
the names of the jane does
to build a defense could that possibly
be the next step in these lawsuits
absolutely if and when these suits are
all filed watson has a right to
know and fully understand what the
charges are against him
including the names having said that
though brian
those names could be kept confidential
and maybe never revealed to the public
and you know you've seen this in other
cases like weinstein and epstein where
they start out as anonymous but at the
end of the day some of these individuals
might actually come
forth and say what their names are all
right we'll keep eyes on that and see
whether or not these names get published
terry thank you very much and thank you
for joining us here along crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you